ich möchte alle anwesenden begrüßen wir
sehen die referentinnen und referenten
die aus ganz verschiedenen fachbereichen
kommen dann aber auch die übrigen
teilnehmer ich gebe eine ganz kurze
einleitung zum thema der tagung bevor
dann der erste referent herr krawitz mit
seinem vortrag beginnen wird
wozu eine tagung über das böse und dann
gleich noch eine interdisziplinäre
sollte man den begriff des bösen nicht
lieber in den keller dunkler schlecht
metaphysischer zeiten verbannen in ein
museum überholter begriffe die
heutzutage keine geltung mehr
beanspruchen können oder sollte man
stattdessen nicht lieber neutralere
begriffe verwenden vom schlechten oder
kranken sprechen dass in der welt
zweifellos existiert und das zum guten
und gesunden verbessert werden kann oder
gar nur von schwächen fehlern und
defiziten die wir bei ausreichender
anstrengung pflege und gegebenenfalls
therapie überwinden können besteht nicht
die gefahr dass wir mit der verwendung
des begriffs des bösen einzelne menschen
gesellschaften oder ganze teile der welt
zu gegenständen eines schwarz weiß den
kann es machen und auf diese weise
diskriminieren aber wie verhält sich die
zweifellos vorhandene faszination des
bösen von der die hohen einschaltquoten
und auch die große anmeldezahl die sich
jetzt noch nicht so niederschlägt aber
die noch zu erwarten ist
zeugen auch allabendliche krimis und
horror fällen und so weiter es scheint
dass eine auffassung des bösen als
bloßes defizit oder mangel dem phänomen
nicht gerecht werden kann vielmehr legt
seine faszination nahe dass es sich auch
dabei teilweise um eine herausragende
eigenschaft halten kanten kann im sinne
einer besonders perfiden intelligenz die
zugleich gefürchtet und bewundert werden
kann das ist auch der grund dafür warum
besonders die bösewichte in der
literatur und im film so viel raum
einnehmen
das ist also das problem erst da wo das
böse in diesem sinne als willentliche
und zurechenbare aktivität verstanden
wird wird es uns zur problem das wäre
meine these wir können darüber
diskutieren denn es betrifft da nicht
nur bestimmte gegebene charakterzüge
oder äußerlichkeiten sondern zielt
mitten hinein in das zentrum mensch die
existenz in das zentrum der freien
existenz die gründe des bösen sind dann
abgründe der tübinger philosoph und wir
haben hier eine tübinger professorin
unter uns auch der tübinger philosoph
otfried höffe hat vor nicht allzu langer
zeit behauptet dass die gegenwärtige
philosophie das böse als thema verloren
habe und das böse für die philosophie
wiedergewonnen werden müsse allerdings
stellt sich die frage ob die philosophie
das thema böse jemals besessen hat und
das thema als das bild das thema das
böse als thema zu besitzen müsste die
philosophie ein begriff oder eine
ausgearbeitete theorie davon haben eine
wissenschaft des bösen kann es eine
solche theorie des bösen aber überhaupt
geben könnte der grund der beobachtung
dass die philosophie das böse als thema
verloren habe am ende nicht gerade darin
liegen dass sich den begriff immer schon
entzieht dass das böse das system
springt also prinzipiell gar keine
theorie davon geben kann und sollte dann
das böse sein platz nicht am allerbesten
sein platz im märchen mythen oder
schauergeschichten haben bei all diesen
schwierigkeiten möchte die anstehende
tagung die heute morgen stattfinden wird
dazu beitragen den begriff und das
phänomen des bösen weiter aufzuklären
erfolgen kann dieser zugang dabei nicht
nur durch die theologie und die
philosophie die den hauptteil ausmachen
wird des heutigen tages dessen die
traditionelle zugänge zu diesem thema
sondern wie ich meine nur
multiperspektivische und
interdisziplinär ziel der tagung ist es
deswegen durch verschiedene annäherungen
ein begriff des bösen zu profilieren der
seine berechtigung darin hat dass er
dessen phänomene und handlungen auf
ihren grund in der menschlichen trakt
der menschlichen freiheit die ganz
verschiedentlich ausfallen kann
ästhetisch durch die musik wie auch
immer hin transparent macht die
interdisziplinäre veranstaltung wird
sich also an zwei tagen dem phänomen des
bösen aus verschiedenen perspektiven
mehr im zentrum steht die frage wie das
böse begrifflich ästhetisch und
naturwissenschaftlich weitesten sinne
jetzt verstanden werden kann
vertreterinnen und vertreter folgende
fachbereiche sind an der tagung
beteiligt theologie philosophie
kulturwissenschaft anglistik soziologie
politikwissenschaft rechtswissenschaft
und zum schluss forensische psychiatrie
die tagung hat drei teile
am heutigen tag stehen theologische und
philosophische konzeption des bösen im
zentrum am morgigen tag für die
perspektive weiter ausgedehnt vormittags
für das böse aus literatur und musik
ästhetischer sicht betrachtet am
nachmittag gehen wir dann über zur
politikwissenschaft zur
rechtswissenschaft und schließlich zur
forensischen psychiatrie ich wünsche uns
allen eine produktive tagung und
verbindet diesen wunsch mit der hoffnung
dass das wissenschaftliche reden über
das böse dazu beiträgt die welt ein ganz
klein bisschen zu verbessern denn so
glaube ich auch das sprechen ist eine
handlung die gut oder böse sein kann um
so mehr als jüngst die hamburger
philosophin bettina stangneth den
begriff des akademischen bösen geprägt
hat das akademische böse so stammt ist
kein versehen auch keine banalität des
bösen als auch kein mangel an
vorstellungskraft sondern ein böses das
wissen und denkern instrumentalisiert
und dabei so klug und konsequent vorgeht
dass die intelligenz dahinter nicht zu
verbergen ist das wollen wir also nicht